you spoke of globalization shaping modes
of
formal religious authority is found now
and networks of believers in that sense
do you think that globalization can kind
of be driving perpetuation of religion
instead of globalization arcade for
modernization yeah I think in many ways
what I said indicates that globalization
is giving rise to in some senses giving
rise to to faith so it's not it's not
that faiths are holding their own
somehow right and globalization
processes globalization processes are
bearing on them but rather that the very
globalization processes are creating the
need the desire however explainable in
people for religion and obviously the
globalization processes are providing
very powerful means of transmission of
those faiths modes of reaching people
there big debates within the within
religious communities are those modes of
transmission really appropriate they
thin out to faith they are too sleek
they're they're too much driven by by
kind of market mentality they are not
able to express the depth of faith and
there are a lot of religious people who
are very disdainful not necessarily of
these means as such but them as means of
mediating faith because faith is
something much deeper happens between
people involved in presences of people
you know all the reformer Martin Luther
he never thought that the written word
was appropriate mode of spreading faith
you have to look a person in the eyes
speak a living word that is attuned to
the concrete presence of the self and so
far